denn
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
ich habe heute wieder ein richtig
leckeres rezept für euch denn ich habe
eine doppelte schrank torte kreiert und
zwar ist es diese torte hier ganz ohne
backen
ich habe nämlich unten einen brösel
boden mit vollkorn keksen und toto dann
eine richtig cremige füllung und ihn bei
frucht einlage und zwar habe ich euch ja
letzte woche schon eine jobbörse lust
orte gezeigt und ich habe in kooperation
mit jj zehn rezepte kreiert als es sind
wirklich 10c die rezepte und dieses
rezept und auch mal ein weiterer findet
ihr übrigens in diesen aktionspackungen
und die gibt es jetzt für kurze zeit im
handel
am ende des videos gibt es übrigens noch
ein richtig tolles gewinnspiel aber
jetzt zeige ich euch erstmal die zutaten
für diese leckere torte zuerst stelle
ich jetzt den boden her und für den
kloster boden brauche ich 200 gramm
vollkornkekse 100 gramm butter und drei
stangen giotto zuerst gebe ich jetzt die
butter auf den herd die habe ich schon
einen topf und zerlassener butter dann
bei mittlerer hitze und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die
kekse zerkleinern und zwar geht es jetzt
entweder in einem mixer oder ihr steckt
die kekse in einen gefrierbeutel und
haut einfach einem ausbaustopp drauf
die lottokugeln zerkleinert jetzt auch
im mixer und jetzt kann ich alle zutaten
zusammen in der schüssel verrühren
die fertige maße fülle ich jetzt in
einen bug rahmen
den habe ich mit backpapier
eingeschlagen und ihn auf 26 cm gestellt
und ich habe da jetzt so eine
tortenplatte darunter also ein
tortenheber dann kann ich das ganze
richtig gut vorbereiten und in brüssel
boden für dich da jetzt ein und muss ihn
schön flach drücken damit das fest wird
zuerst verteile ich ihnen jetzt
und dann könnt ihr ihn zum beispiel auch
mit einem glas fest drücken oder mit so
einem holzknüppel
den brösel bodenständig jetzt für eine
halbe stunde in den kühlschrank und
zeigt euch in der zwischenzeit schon mal
die zutat für dich in der frucht
einlagen für die himbeer frucht einlage
brauchen wir 200 gramm beeren die sind
jetzt aus dem tiefkühlfach 150
milliliter himbeersirup und 40 km
speisestärke und es geht jetzt auch ganz
schnell
ich gebe ziel basiere und speisestärke
in einen kleinen topf und früher alles
gut mit einem schneebesen so dass eben
keine klümpchen mehr ab
jetzt kommen auch direkt die himbeeren
mit dazu und weil ich ja jetzt den
hinweis europa brauche ich da jetzt auch
kein zug also das ist dann wirklich süß
genug aber immer noch säuerlich also
dass wir später einfach schöne
komponenten abenteuerliches knusprig
cremig und jetzt lasse ich alles
aufkochen
die himbeer mischung dürfte jetzt einmal
aufkochen jetzt habe ich sie vom
heruntergezogen und falls die himba
jetzt noch nicht genug zerkleinert sind
also ich hab so ein bisschen schnee
wissen verdrückt dann können das jetzt
einmal noch durchführen oder durch mixen
aber bei mir ist es jetzt wirklich schön
zerkleinert und jetzt warte ich einfach
so etwa zehn minuten bis es abgekühlt
ist
in der zeit ist der boden dann auch
gekühlt und dann kann man gleich die
torte zusammenstellen die hinweg creme
ist jetzt kalt der knospe boden ist kalt
und jetzt habe ich hier vorne noch die
zutaten für die creme und für die
dekoration
sie zeige ich euch mal ganz kurz für die
creme brauche ich 400 gramm schlagsahne
vier teelöffel sah da stand mittel 400
gramm frischkäse 500 gramm magerquark
150 gramm puderzucker und nochmal vier
teelöffel sahne stand mittel und für die
dekoration vier stangen giotto zwei
stangen giotto wir gehen aber auch haben
merkel mit dabei also zuerst einmal die
creme her und zwar gebe ich dafür die
sahne in eine rührschüssel ich mach das
jetzt kurz in der küchenmaschine und
kann in der zeit dann nehme ich die
festliche creme vorbereiten
es liegt die kurz gerührt und dann gebe
ich die fahne stand mittel dazu und
schlagt die sahne steif
das hat jetzt auch nicht zu lange und
kann in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
anderen zutaten verrühren
also frischkäse
da der quark mit drin
der puderzucker jedes gesät
die sahne ist steif die las ich ganz
kurz hier warten
und gewiss auch das restliche sahne
steif mittel mit zur creme und früher da
kurz durch und dabei niedriger stufe
anfangen sonst spritzt gleich in der
küche herum
und jetzt kann ich die frisch käsecreme
noch unter die sahne heben und euch
bestimmt aufgefallen also mir geht es
wirklich gut aber heute wirklich kein
wandel extrakt genutzt wir können uns
natürlich gerne noch benutzen
aber ich möchte heute dass wir wirklich
nur dich in bern und die haselnüsse
schmeckt deswegen am set weggelassen
wäre jetzt ganz vorsichtig sein könnte
auch ganz kurz mit dem schneebesen
einmal durchführen
jetzt kann ich die torte schon zusammen
setzen und streich jetzt die hälfte der
frischkäse creme auf den boden und ihr
seht ist das wirklich eine ganz schnelle
torte man richtig tolle kühlschrank
worte so kurz verstreichen das muss
jetzt auch nicht so gleichmäßig sein
man verteile ich seit diesem weg gehen
und davon auch die hälfte einfach soplex
artig dann haben später beim anschnitt
richtig tolle knicks mit drin
man verteile ich da jetzt auch die
lottokugeln hast du nur von einer stange
natürlich können auch mehr mit rein
geben aber noch mac nutzer mit drin
und jetzt kommt die rest creme obenauf
und die creme die verstreicht jetzt so
ein bisschen unregelmäßig also gewollt
unregelmäßig und jetzt gebe ich da noch
die team bei kremin klecksen oben drauf
und wenn die jetzt mittlerweile bisschen
fester geworden ist könnt ihr noch ein
bisschen sirup mit rein geben und das
ganze noch mal so ein bisschen
geschädigt werden
die kleckse könnte jetzt mit einem
löffel schön in form ziehen
mit wie die torte noch mit frischen
himbeeren und mit schotter kugeln
verziert die könnte jetzt zum beispiel
auch auf schneiden oder einfach im
gesamten drauflegen und dann kommt
eigentlich der schwierigste part und
zwar müsst ihr dann die torte wirklich
leider für drei stunden im kühlschrank
stellen
denn erst wenn es richtig kalt ist
können wir sie später anschneiden
die sorte ist jetzt karl zuletzt ist
unser weg und zwar geht es am
einfachsten wenn es um platz und dann so
kroll
jetzt kann ich nämlich die torte auf
eine schönere platte setzen
und ich setze ich nehme doch danach erst
den springform rand also den torten rand
jetzt einfach mit einer toten palette
mit einem paletten messer hier entlang
sein
jetzt kann ich die torte anschneiden es
sehe ich das schönste teil des videos
wird müsste auch ganz durchschneiden den
wir haben unten diesen knusper boden
dann macht ihr das messer auch am besten
immer wieder das sauber damit die torte
auch richtig schön bleibt
da haben wir dieses wunderschöne leckere
kuchen stück und zwar habe ich da jetzt
diesen leckeren knuspern boden mit dem
motto kugeln dann die cremige füllung
und die himbeer frucht einlage die
einfach so ein bisschen frischer mit in
die torte bringt und ich konnte es am
anfang nicht so ganz vorstellen als ich
das rezept zur geschrieben habe aber
dort wo also haselnuss und hin wenn es
passt wirklich super zusammen schmeckt
wirklich total lecker sehr erfrischend
und einfach mal was anderes
und jetzt kommen wir zum gewinnspiel und
zwar hab ich ja dieses rezept und neun
weitere mit toto für euch kreiert und
jetzt seid ihr an der reihe und zwar hab
jetzt die einmalige chance eine von
diesen zehn maschinen oder 1 von 500 job
paket zu gewinnen und zwar müsste jetzt
nur auch ein rezept mit toto kreieren
dieses rezept mit bild auf dieser unten
eingeblendeten seite hochladen
das ganze geht bis zum 30.06 und dann
werden die otto schily und ich die
besten rezepte aussuchen und ich würde
mal sagen ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz
viel spaß beim backen ganz mit
kreativität beim aussuchen der rezepte
und mein rezept gibt wie gewohnt auch
sallys - blog.de oder 1 von 10 in diesem
motto aktionspackungen also viel spaß
beim backen und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder bis dahin tschüss